[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
تقارير امريكيه تتحدث عن سفينه روسيه رست
في جنوب افريقيا وتحمل شحنه اسلحه مخبا
للكرملين
حاله الطوارئ اذا فشل مجلس النواب والدوله
في التوافق بشان الانتخابات
ترامب يدعو لمداهمه منزل بايدن بعد اكتشاف
وثائق سريه كانت بحوزته حينما كان نائبا
لاوباما
الامير هاري يكشف تسريبات خطيره عن
العائله البريطانيه الملكيه ومذكراته
تتضمن المزيد
حياكم الله البدايه من واشنطن حيث كشفت
صحيفه
عن سفينه تجاريه روسيه ليدي ار بانها تحمل
على متنها اسلحه مخبا وزعمت انها تحمل
شحنه اسلحه للكرملين وقالت الصحيفه عن
مصادر ان السفينه اوقفت اجهزه الارسال
والاستقبال لديها الشهر الماضي لتر في
ميناء سيمون تاون في اكبر قاعده بحريه
جنوب افريقيا سلطات جنوب افريقيا لم تقدم
اي معلومات عن حموله السفينه والتي تم
تفريغها في القاعده مخاوف امريكيه طرحها
مسؤولون من ان تكون السفينه التي تخضع
للعقبات الامريكيه تحمل بالفعل ذخائر من
روسيا وقد اكدت مصادر وصف جورنال هذه
المعلومات
اقرت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه بان القوات
الروسيه ومجموعات فاجنر حققت تقدما
تكتيكيا في بلده سوليدار شرقي اوكرانيا
وسيطرت على معظم مناطق البلده في الايام
الاربعه الماضيه وقالت الوزاره في بيانها
اليوم روسيا وضعت السيطره على السوليدار
هدفا رئيسا لتطويق مدينه باخ مودات الموقع
الاستراتيجي من جهه الشمال وتعطيل خطوط
الاتصال بين الوحدات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
ورغم ذلك استبعدت الدفاع البريطانيه نجاح
روسيا في تطويق قريبا مشيره الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحتفظ بخطوط دفاعيه مستقره
وتتحكم في طرق الامداد بالمدينه من جانبه
وصف مسؤول عسكري امريكي
ان الولايات المتح كده ستتابع ارسال
الدفاعات الجويه لاوكرانيا وتاتي هذه
التصريحات في الوقت الذي تدور فيه معارك
عنيفه بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه على
طول خطوط التماس في دنيتك شرق اوكرانيا
الرئيس الاوكراني فولدي ميرسي قال ان قوته
تصمد امام هجمات جديده واكثر شده حتى على
سوليدار قرب مدينه باخمود في شرق البلاد
والتي تحاول موسكو سيطر عليها منذ اشهر
ويظهرون اقصى قدر من المرونه اشكر جميع
الجنود في سوليدير الذين صمدوا امامها
الغازات الجديده والاكثر صرافه انه امر
بالغ الصعوبه تقريبا كامله
من دنيتك معانا رغد الاغبر مراسل العربيه
اهلا بك معنا رائد ما اقرا المستجدات على
ارض المعركه لديك
يعني ما زالت المعارك مستمره في الشرق
الاوكراني وترتفع وتيره القصف المتبادل ما
بين الطرفين في مقاطعه الثانيه في المحور
الشمالي حول مدينه
حيثما اسلفت تتقدم قوات بانر من الناحيه
الشماليه من مدينه باخم حيث بلده سندار
المتاخمه لباخ يعني سيطرت خلال اليومين
الماضيين على ثلاثه
واخرها يوم امس كان باقي نصف سكان
شوارع عنيف داخل بلده سيدي دار
سيطره القوات الخاصه الروسيه نتحدث عن
قوات راجنر وقوات كبيره وحتى القوات
الشعبيه من مقاطعه لوغانسكار التي تقدمت
من المحور الشمالي لقربها من يعني ارض
المعركه همم ربما خلال ساعات او خلال ايام
همم تنتهي هذه المعارك لان الجانب
الاوكراني بنفسه وصف صعوبه الموقف على
الجنود ويعني لابد لهم من الانسحاب للحفاظ
على حياتهم على الاقل حسب المعطيات يعني
ما يردنا من ارض المعركه همم بالفعل همم
هنا قصف عنيف ساعد القوات الروسيه بالسيطر
على الموقف معارك سندار همم نقطه اتصال مع
القمر الصناعي
حيث قطع قطع الجيش الروسي الاتصال ما بين
المقاتلين على الجبهات وما بين
القياده العسكريه للجيش الاوكراني كما ان
همم
الاليات العسكريه الروسيه نقصد القوات
الصاروخيه قصفت امدادات عسكريه بشريه كانت
تتجه من مدينه باخبط الى سندار لدعم
القوات التي تقاتل في داخل بلده سيلدار
هذه
العاجل الذي يريدنا من سكرتير مجلس الامن
الروسي الذي يقول ان من المهم انت تمتلك
روسيا جيشا قويا لمواجهه التهديدات الا
تمتلك روسيا جيشيا قويا بالفعل
طبعا
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه اظهرت كثير من
الاخطاء التي يعني اعتمدت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
واداره الرئيس الروسي الذي مر الى تصحيح
هذه الاخطاء وهمم يعني تقويم الجيش الروسي
همم ودعمه بالمقومات البشريه وايضا
العسكريه لكن لابد من الاشاره ايضا فاطمه
اذا سمحت لنا الى ان
همم القصب الاوكراني على مدينه دانيتك
نقصد القصف على مناطق المدنيين انخفض خلال
ال 24 ساعه الماضيه ذلك لاهتمام الجانب
الاوكراني بنقل الامدادات العسكريه من
محور وسط اليد الى المنطقه الشماليه حيث
باخم وحيث تطوق القوات الروسيه مدينه باخم
من الناحيه الجنوبيه والشرقيه والشماليه
تشهد مع ضاريا من اجل دفع الجيش الروسي
للانسحاب عفوا الاوكراني للانسحاب من
مدينه الى المناطق التي تتمركز فيها قواعد
اوكرانيه العربيه
صحيفه بوليتكو مشاهدينا الذكرت نقلا عن
مصدرين ان الولايات المتحده تدرس تقديم
عربات مدرعه من نوع سترايكر لاوكرانيا
وقالت الصحيفه ايضا ان مدرعات سترايكر قد
تكون ضمن الحزم القادمه من المساعدات
العسكريه مشيره الى ان الاوكرانيين
يحتاجون الى ناقلات الجنود المدرعه لصد
هجوم الربيع المتوقع من القوات الروسيه
بينما صحيفه جورنال اكدت في تقرير لها ان
ممثلين عن اداره الرئيس جوبيدا كشفوا ان
البنتاجون يواجه صعوبات في تزويد اوكرانيا
بانظمه استطلاع وضرب نموذجيه للتصدي
للطائرات المسيره
واضافت الصحيفه نقلا عن مصادرها ان واشنطن
كانت وعدت بتوريد هذا النوع تحديدا من
الاسلحه في اغسطس الماضي
مع شركه التصنيع هايبرس بقيمه تقدم
باربعين مليون دولار وهو ملاكفي بكميات
الكبيره التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا وفقا للت
الدبابه البريطانيه تشالنجر 2
دبابه قتاليه مصممه لتنفيذ مهام هجوميه
دخلت الخدمه في الجيش البريطاني عام
1994 تم نشرها في البوسنه والهرسك وكسوفو
والعراق
يمكنها اصابته ثمانيه اهداف مختلفه في
الدقيقه الواحده
تتميز بنظام الكتروني للتحكم بكثافه
النيران الجيش البريطاني قال ان ارسال عشر
دبابات تشالنجر 2 سيمثل تسعيدا كبيرا في
الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
نشيل لهذا العاجل المشاهدين الذي يردنا من
سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي الذي يقول ان
الصراع في اوكرانيا يتحول لمواجهه بين
روسيا ونيتو وفي سياق نشرتنا اجره الفرقه
الروسيه الاميرال جوشكوف اول منورات
العسكريه لها بعد دخولها الخدمه في بحر
النرويج وقالت الدفاع الروسيه ان
المناورات هذه ركزت على مواجهه اهداف جويه
باسلحه ناريه مضاده للطائرات وتدميرها
الكترونيه وكان الرئيس الروسي بوت اكد
خلال اطلاق الفريقات المسلحه بصواريخ
سيركن ان بلاده ستواصل تطويل القدره
القتاليه للقوات المسلحه وانتاج اسلحه
متطوره ارجعت كل من ايطاليا والمانيا خطه
لتسليم اوكرانيا مدرعات بسبب مالي اقتصادي
ونقص المخزون
خطه الغرب لتسريح اوكرانيا في حربها ضد
روسيا
بين السرعه
الاولى بريطانيا تبحث تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
قبل نهايه مارس
نشره اليوم مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل واسطه
تمديد دوليا للمحاكمات الثوريه الايرانيه
تتواصل ضد المحتاجين ومنظمه حقوقيه تقول
ان اكثر من متظاهر مهددون بالاعدام
احييكم من جديد اعلنت منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه ان 109 متظاهرين معرضون لخاطر
اصدار او تنفيذ احكام الاعدام في ايران
بحقهم واكدت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
ومقرها النرويج ان النظام الايراني يحاول
متعمدا اشاعه الغموض حول قضايا المعتقلين
عبر التصريحاته متناقضه في ملفاتهم وخاصه
المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام ودعاه المنظمات
والمجتمع المدنيه الايراني والدولي الى
تسليط الضوء على القمر المكثف للنظام
الايراني اثناء الاحتجاج والاستجواب
واصدار احكام جماعيه وعنبر الامن القومي
الامريكي
لاعدام محمد مهدي ومحمد حسين في ايران
واعلام عن المزيد من احكام الاعدام ودعاء
طالب من النظام الايراني الى وقفه عمليات
الاعدام فورا ملوحا بمحاسبه ايران على
سلوكها
تواصل في ايران
ثلاثه اشخاص ينضمون الى لائحه المحكوم
عليهم بالاعدام
ليصل العدد الاجمالي الى 17 شخصا
تم تنفيذه اربعه منها لحد الان
محسن شكاري
[موسيقى]
محمد مهدي كرامي
فتح حسيني
[موسيقى]
جميع الذين تم اعدامهم اتهموا بقتل اعضاء
من رجال الامن
المحكمه العليا صادقت على حكمين اخرين
ينتظران لتنفيذ فقط
[موسيقى]
الله الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
اي اختلافا في الموقف بين بلاده واسرائيل
بشان ايران واكد في رده للعربيه ان هناك
اجماعا بين الطرفين بعدم السماح لايران
بامتلاكي اسلحه النوويه
نتيجه على المستوى الاستراتيجي هناك اجماع
المطلق وهناك اجماع مطلق مع شركائنا
الاسرائيليين كلانا ملتزم تماما بحقيقه ان
ايران يجب ان لا تكون ابدا قادره على
امتلاك سلاح النووي هذا هو التزام الرئيس
بيض هذا هو نفسه الالتزام الذي سمعناه من
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو انه بالمناسبه نفس
الالتزام الذي سمعناه من نتنياه واسلافه
لذا فنحن على قدم وساق عندما يتعلق الامر
بهذا الهدف الاستراتيجي ليس هناك سر وقد
البحر سلفا الى انه عندما يتعلق الامر
لكيفيه القيام بذلك فقد تكون هناك بعض
الاختلافات التكتيكيه هناك بعض الاختلافات
التكتيكيه نحن لم نخفي ذلك لدينا علاقه
وثيقه مع اسرائيل بما يكفي
بما يكفي للسماح لنا باجراء محادثات صريحه
وعندما نختلف نقول لهم ما نفكر فيه وهم
بالتاكيد لا يخجلون من اخبارنا بما يفكرون
فيه نحن نؤمن بان الدبلوماسيه هي الوسيله
الاكثر قابليه للتطبيق والاستدامه لمنع
ايران بشكل دائم وقابل للتحقق من الحصول
على سلاح النووي لكننا نتفق ايضا مع
شركائنا الاسرائيليين على انه لا ينبغي
لنا ازاله اي شيء من على الطاوله نحن لم
ناخذ اي شيء من على الطاوله
عايزين
الحقيقه التي يجب ان تكون واضحه للجميع في
هذه القاعه بان الايرانيين قتلوا احتمال
العوده السريعه الى الامتثال لخطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه والعوده الى الاتفاق
ليست مطروحه على جدول الاعمال انها ليست
على جدول الاعمال لسبب الرئيسيين واحد هو
ان الايرانيين اداروا ظهورهم لها
ولكثف الايرانيون بالالتزاماتهم ونحن نركز
اولا وقبل كل شيء في الوقت الحالي على ما
يمكن القيام به لدعم الشعب الايراني
الشجاع الذي يخرج الى الشوارع في جميع
انحاء ايران
وفي رده عن سؤال للعربيه حول ما اذا عادت
ايران مستقبلا وقالت انها على استعداد
لاستئناف المحادثات ولكن استبعد نت برايس
ترحيب الجانب الامريكي بهذه الخطوه لان
ايران لا يمكن تصديقها كما قال
بعد دبلوماسيه لكن في ظل عدم وجود اي
اهتمام حقيقي بالدبلوماسيه من جانب
الايرانيين سنواصل تركيزنا على دعم الشعب
الايراني مع استمرار تركيزنا على مواجهه
المساعده الامنيه الايرانيه لروسيا
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه اعلنت عن مكافاه
تصل لعشره ملايين دولار امريكي لمن يدلي
بمعلومات عن اثنين من مواليشيات حزب الله
في لبنان وطالب برنامج مكافات من اجل
العداله التابع للخارجيه الامريكيه عبر
تويتر طلبه بتقديم معلومات عن انشطه كل من
علي سعاده ابراهيم طاهر والمصنفين
كارهابيين دوليين الى جانب توفير معلومات
عن شركتهما وزملائهم
شهدت القاهره لقاء مفاجئ جمع رئيس المجلس
الرئاسي الليبي محمد المنفي بقائد الجيش
الوطني المشير خليفه حفتر وذكرت مصادر
للعربيه ان الاجتماع ناقشت تطورات
السياسيه وتثبيت جهود التهدئه بين اطراف
الازمه الليبيه مضيفا ان لم يلف اقترح
اعلان حاله الطوارئ وحل مجلس الدوله
والنواب والحكمتين واستلام زمن الامور
سياسيه في حال الفشل في الوصول الى قاعده
دستوريه واجراء انتخابات في الوقت ذاته
اجرى قائد الجيش الوطني الليبي خليفه حفتر
محادثات مع مسؤولين مصريين لوضع خريطه
الطريق لتوحيد المؤسسات العسكريه
والمؤسسات الامنيه
ينضم الينا من القاهره مراسل العربيه احمد
عثمان اهلا بك احمد ما الجديد لديك حول
هذا الاجتماع المفاجئ الذي جرى في القاهره
يعني هذا الاجتماع يراه البعض ان كان يراه
البعض مفاجئا فان هناك اخرون من يقراونه
بانه ياتي في سياق واحد حول تحركات
القاهره خلال الفتره الاخيره فيما يتعلق
بالازمه الليبيه شاهدنا هنا في القاهره
عدد من اللقاءات الليبيه الليبيه المهمه
كان هناك لقاءات ما بين ال- همم السيد همم
المستشار خالد المشدي مع السيد المستشار
عقيده صالح ايضا امس راينا لقاء ما بين
السيد محمد المنسي والمشير خليفه حفتر
هناك من يقرا بان هذه اللقاءات التي تتم
في القاهره برعايه المصريه تدوم جميع
الفرقاء الذي بين ربما باستثناء السيد عبد
الحميد الدبيبه رئيس الحكومه المنتهيه
التي يرى كثيرون بانه يعني هو المعرقد
فكره استئناف للجهود والوصول الى انتخابات
وبالتالي هناك من يرى بان ما يجري في
القاهره يتم قراءته على انه محاوله للوصول
الى حل جذري فيما يتعلق بالازمه الليبيه
المستفده ربما منذ سنوات بسبب تعنت الكثير
من الاطراف للوصول الى مشهد الانتخابات
الذي ينادي به الجميع سواء فيما يتعلق
بالمجتمع الدولي والمشهد الليبي وايضا
المشهد الاقليمي وايضا اجتماع الامس ربما
يحدد لاول مره ملامح في حال فشل هذا
الوصول لهذا المشهد يعني نحن نتحدث الان
بان هناك الجهود رامي للوصول الى مشهد
الانتخابات هناك الكثير من الاجتماعات
التي تمت ومن بينها اجتماعات في القاهره
للوصول الى قاعده دستوريه وهو الرهان
الرئيس على امكانيه ان يكون هناك نجاح هذه
المره وتحت هذا الكم من الضغوط والتحديات
من المجتمع الدولي ما بين المجلسين همم
الدوله ومجلس البرلمان للوصول الى قاعده
دستوريه وتجاوز كل الخلافات التي يرى
البعض بانها تشكل اقل من 10% من مجموعه تم
اتفاق عليها للوصول ماشي الانتخابات
والخروج بالازمه الليبيه من المشهد
السياسي الراهن والانتقال الى مشهد سياسي
جديد وربما كما ذكرت لك اصبح الحديث الان
يدور في حال فشل هذه المحادثات او الوصول
الى هذه المعادله السياسيه ما هو البديل
ربما خلال الايام المقبله ستكون القاهره
ايضا شهده على مجموعه اخرى من اللقاءات
هناك من يرى بان القاهره تكثف بشكل كبير
جدا من همم يعني همم علاقاتها مع كل
الفرقاء الليبيين للوصول لهذا المشهد
السياسي الجديد
احمد عثمان
من مصر الى ليبيا حيث تستمر فعاليات اليوم
الثاني للملتقى التحضيري لمؤتمر المصالحه
الوطنيه والذي يشرف عليه المجلس الرئاسي
الليبي رعايه من الاتحاد الافريقي تقرير
منير الاشهاب
الجديد
الازمه السياسيه الليبيه وفي هذا المكان
يجتمع ممثلين عن جميع اطياف القوه
السياسيه الليبيه بما فيهم ممثلين عن سيف
الاسلام القذافي لمحاولته
صحيحه لملف المصالحه الليبيه
اكثر من 100 شخص حظروا هذه الاجتماعات بعد
تقسيمهم الى ست مجموعات لوضع الاطر
الاساسيه في مشروع المصالحه الوطنيه
الليبيه جلسات تستمر حتى نهايه الاسبوع
من القضايا الجوهريه في مسار المصالحه على
سبيل المثال مسار العداله الانتقاليه شكل
العداله الانتقاليه التعامل مع المركزيه
وعدد اخر من القضايا الجوهريه المتصله
بالمصالحه
الشائكه
ورصدهم المشاركه في فعاليات اليوم الاول
بسبب وجود العالم والافتتاح بالنشيد هكر
صفوه الاجتماعات
[موسيقى]
الاطراف التي لربما لديها بعض الملاحظات
انا اثمن فيهم دورهم الكبير ودورهم المهم
في نجاح هذا المشروع الوطني وكما قلت
هذا المشروع هو مفتاح الحل للعمليه
السياسيه في ليبيا
وتجاوز
النقاط الخلافيه ومعالجه النقاط الخلافيه
لابد ان تكون عبر حوار وطني شامل وهو ما
نعمل عليه الان ما يميز هذا الملتقى
اقامته على ارض الليبيه وبحضور مندوبين عن
جميع الفئات مما يجعله نتائجها اكثر قبولا
للتطبيق على ارض الواقع منير الاشهب
طرابلس العربيه العربيه
نظام عمر البشير اولى خطوات تنفيذ خارطه
الاتفاق السياسي
رقصات في جنوب افريقيا وتحملي شحنه اسلحه
مخبئه للكرمله
حاله الطوارئ اذا فشل مجلس النواب والدوله
في التوافق بشان الانتخابات
سريه كانت بحوزته حينما كان نائبا
والامير هاري يكشف تسريبات خطيره عن
العائله البريطانيه الملكيه ومذكراته
تتضمن المزيد
حياكم الله من جديد في السودان اعلن رئيس
البعثه الامميه
ان المرحله النهائيه من العمليه السياسيه
تبشر باقتراب التواصل لحل الازمه السياسيه
التي استمرت اكثر من عام في البلاد ومع
بدء مؤتمر تجديد تجديد تفكيك نظام البشير
اشاره كل الاطراف المواقع من العسكريين
والمدنيين والمجتمع الدولي اكدت على اهميه
هذه العمليه مؤكدا ان العمليه السياسيه
السودانيه سودانيه بكل مضامينها وان
الاليات الثلاثيه تساعد وتيسر الحوار بين
اطراف الاتفاق متوقعا ان تقود هذه العمليه
الى حل توافقيا بين كل السودانيين
نهائيا
من الخرطوم مراسله العربيه لنا يعقوب اهلا
بك لينا ما ابرز ما تم في اليوم الاول من
ورشه
المتعلقه بتفكيك نظام الثلاثين من يونيو
صباح الخير عليك فاطمه هي نقاشات وتداولات
واوراق عمل تقدم خلال هذه الورشه المتعلقه
بمراجعه همم لجنه تفكيك نظام 30 من يونيو
اللافته ان هناك كثير من اوراق العمل التي
قضد التي قدمت ومن بينها مراجعه عمل
اللجنه وقد تحدث الرئيس المناوب لان
اللجنه عن عمل لجنه التفكيك وتحدث انها
كانت مثل الراس المصلط على النظام السابق
يقصد طبعا نظام عمر البشير هو تجنب الحديث
عن اخطاء عمل اللجنه وكانت هناك اخطاء
للجنه باعتراف اللجنه نفسها حينما كانت
تعمل اليوم من المقرر ان تقدم اوراق عمل
اخرى جديده متعلقه بتجارب الدول الاقليميه
والدوليه في مكافحه الفساد هناك كثير من
المختصين واصحاب الخبرات فضلا عن
السياسيين والصحفيين يناقشونه في هذه
الجلسات بعض هذه الجلسات مغلق وبعضها
مفتوح وسائل الاعلام من المقرر ان تنتهي
بعد اربعه ايام على ان تقدم توصيات نهائيه
تتفق عليها كفتى الاطراف الحضور من ممثلين
لكل القوى الواقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
حتى تتفق ان كانت هذه التوصيات من المقرر
ان تضمن في الوثيقه الدستوريه النهائيه ام
لا لذلك نحن ننظر ونرى هذه النقاشات التي
تتم خلال هذه الورشه وماذا عن تعليقات برد
حول ااه ان ال- همم الاليه الثلاثيه تساهم
في ادخال الرافدين لهذا الاتفاق الايطالى
الموقع علينا
صحيح فاطمه الاليه الثلاثيه هي ترغب في
اشراك القوه الرافضه لكن قبل ثلاثه ايام
كان هناك مؤتمر صحفي للقوى الرافده
للاتفاق الايطالي وكانت هناك اجتماعات
تعقد بينهم بتسيير من الاليه الثلاثيه
تحديدا بين المجلس المركزي والقوه الرافضه
لكنهم اعلنوا ايقاف هذه الاجتماعات لماذا
لانه ورش العمل هذه بدات كانت هناك ايضا
ملاحظات وهي معلومه جديده من قبل القوى
الرافده للاتفاق فيما يتعلق بنت مراجعه
اتفاقيه جوبا الموقعين يرون ان مراجعه
الاتفاقيه لابد ان تتم فقط من قبلهم اي
انها لا تقوم مفتوحه حاليا مثلا مجلس
المركزي والقوه الاخرى لابداء الراي حولها
وهذه نقطه كان فيها خلاف لذلك همم يعني
همم الاليه الثلاثيه ترغب في تنضم هذه
الاطراف ولكن حتى اللحظه لديهم راي اخر
مخالف شكرا لك من الخرطوم مراسله العربيه
لنا يعقوب
منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه مشاهدينا حذرت
من اقدام اسرائيل على تنفيذ اكبر عمليه
تهجير جماعيه في الضفه الغربيه حيث تستعد
لاخلاء سكان ثمانيه قرى وتجمعات من منطقه
المسافر جنوب مدينه الخليل وكانت منظمه
بيت سالم الحقوقيه قد وجهت رساله الى
المدعي العام لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه
طلبته فيها بالتدخل العاجل لوقف مساعي
عمليات التجير
لتغيير القانون وتحديد مصير مئات العائلات
الفلسطينيه اما بالتهجير او انهاء الوجود
انها منطقه عسكريه مغلقه للتدريبات واطلاق
النار ممنوع الدخول
في المنطقه التي يمنع القانون العسكري
الاسرائيلي الدخول اليها عشرات التجمعات
الفلسطينيه عائلات تعيش هنا منذ مئات
السنين قصص وحكايا رجال ونساء واطفال
وبيوت هدمت مرات ومرات وظل اصحابها
يحاولون البقاء ان لم يكن فوق الارض فربما
تحتها كما يفعل عامر دبابسه الذي هدم بيته
واصيبت قدمه في اخره هجوم اسرائيلي ليذهب
لحفر مغاره وتجهيزها ليواء عائلته لعل
باطن الارض يقيه شر سطحها
مش سهل صعب حياه فيه بس لان انا بدي
اتعايش مع الوضع اللي انا فيه وبدي يعني
اضل موجود في الارضي سكان وخلت الضبع
بضروره اخلاء منازلهم وان الجيش
الاسرائيلي سيبحث لهم عن بديل بالاضافه
ثمانيه تجمعات اخرى يقطنها نحو الف نسمه
اقرت المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه ان
باستطاعه اسرائيل ان تضع يدها عليها
واخلاها كونها منطقه عسكريه خاصه
بالتدريبات بعمليات الهدم كانت متكرره
ترجع على الاشجار بدا يعني يطلع فيها كانت
متكرره عندك من الكهرباء
فيعني اخر شيء تعلق لك بموضوع المنطقه
العسكريه ومناطق تدريب الناس في هذه
التجمعات لا يصدقون ذريعه المنطقه
العسكريه وخطرت تدريبات لاسيه وهم يشاهدون
المستوطنات القريبه منهم تنمو وتتكاثر
مؤسسات الحقوقيه وقانونيه تسعى لمساعده
السكان بالتوجه الى المحاكم الدوليه
لثاني اسرائيل عن عمليه الاخلاء والتهجير
التي يبدو انها وشيكه مع ابلاغ الارتباط
الاسرائيلي نظيره الفلسطيني ان الناس سوف
يبلغون وقريبا بضروره الاخلاء وان اسرائيل
سوف تجد لهم بديلا اخر للعيش من منطقه
مسافر يطا عبد الحفيظ جعوان العربيه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وفي شان الامريكيه اعلن البيت الابيض في
بيان له ان محمد رئيس اكتشفوا عاده من
الوثائق السريه في مكتبه السابق في مركز
ابحاث بواشنطن العامه الماضي واضاف البيان
ان الوفاق او تلك الوثائق تعود او يعود
تاريخها الى فتره كان خلالها بيض النائب
للرئيس اوباما من دون ذكر محتواها كما
اوضح البيت الابيض انه اخطر اداره
المحفوظات والسجلات الوطنيه في نفس اليوم
الذي تم فيه العثور على الوثائق ووفقا
لمصادر شبكه سي بي اس فانه وزاره العدل
تقوم بمراجعه الموقف لتحديد كيفيه
عن لقاء الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب على
الخبر متسائلا متى سيقوم مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي بمداهمه العديد من منازل على
غرار مداهمه منزله ومن معركه الوثائق
السريه بين بيضا وترامب الى تحرك
الجمهوريين لمحاسبه الرئيس
حيث يخطط الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب
لاطلاق لجنه تحقيق جديده هذا الاسبوع
ستطلب نسخا من رسائل البريد الالكتروني
والمذكرات الخاصه بالبيت الابيض وغيرها من
الاتصالات مع شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى
حسب ما افادت مصادر رفيعه المستوى لي
اكسكيوز اذا يخطط رئيس مجلس النواب كيف
نوير في لسلسله سريعه من الاجراءات
والاعلانات لمكافاه المتشددين الذين دعموه
خلال معركته والتي انتهت بفوزه برئاسه
المجلس هذا هو يعتبر تشكيل اللجنه الجديده
وهي اللجنه الفرعيه المختره حول تسليح
الحكومه الفدراليه ردان على ما كشف عنه لن
ماسك في الوثائق الداخليه والتي اطلق
عليها ملفات تويتر وسير اسال اللجنه
الفرعيه رئيس اللجنه القضائيه في مجلس
النواب جوردن الذي يعد حليفا مقربا من
كارثه ومفضا لدى اليمنيين وسيبحث التحقيق
عن ما اذا كانت هناك ضغوط حكوميه ادت الى
رقابه او مضايقه المحافظين او اسكات
نقاشات
وفي متابعات الجدل الدائره حول تسريبات
مذكرات الامير هاري والتي من المقرر ان
تطرح او تطرح رسميا اليوم للبيع خرج واكد
خلال مقابله بثتها قناه اي تي في
البريطانيه مؤخرا ان مذكراته التي يضمها
كتابه سبير او الاحتياطي تعد ضروريه كما
نفى الامير هاري ان يكون قد اتهم العائله
المالكه بالعنصريه كما هو متداول في
العامين الماضيين امله في حصول مصالحه
بشرط تحديد المسؤوليات فيما اثار تصريح
الامير هاري استغراء والصحف البريطانيه
خصوصا حيث اعتبرت انه غصن زيتون لافراد
اسرته على حد وصفهها هذا وحدرت كاتبه
بريطانيا من ان كتاب سبير لان الامير هاري
المنتظر نشره بشكل رسمي قد يندر بنهايه
الحكم الملكي في بريطانيا مزيد من
التفاصيل المتابعها
عاوز
الصمت ان يجعل الامور افضل بنسبه الى
الامير البريطانيه
معلومات
وزوجته والده
الملكسب المزيد من التعاطف
اعتقد ان الظهور في الصفحه الاولى جاء من
اعتقاد العائله الملكيه بان التغطيه
الاعلاميه الايجابيه ستحسن سمعتك ميله
وفرص قبولها كمليكه
والده كاميلا بتبادل المعلومات مع الصحافه
للحصول على قصص ايجابيه مكتوبه عنها
الحالي
قرر هؤلاء الاعضاء التعاون مع الشيطان
لاعاده تحسين صورتهم
ثاني حاجه
الساحه لهاري لمهاجمه عائلته خلال سلسله
مقابله تلفزيونيه تسبق الصدور الرسمي
للكتابه
عن زوجته ضد اخيه ويليام وزوجته كيت قائلا
ان الالم الرذيذ
من عائلته الملكيه هناك قوالب نمطيه
منعتهما من التعامل مع زوجته لانها ممثله
امريكيه مطلقه ثنائيه العراق
وما كشفت عنه من تنافر الاسري داخل
العائله
كشفت ما هو اكثر من مجرد خفايا القصر
الملكي بعضها تصريحات تناقضتهامات
العنصريه التي طالت العائله ملكه بريطانيا
في هذا السياق وفي خضم الاسماك قالت
المحلله وكاتبه السيره الذاتيه للملك
تشارلز كافرين نير للصحيفه القادمه ان
الغضب من العنصريه والثروه التي تمتلكها
العائله الملكيه البريطانيه قد ينهي قبول
العامه بالنظام الملكي في البلاد
كاتبه بريطانيا تقول بان كتاب هاري سيكون
بدايه نهايه الحكم الملكي في لندن ما رايك
صباح الخير اعتقد بان يعني هذه جمله همم
لا يمكن ان تكون حقيقيه ولا اعتقد بان
التعبير يصح هنا بان نقول بان قام به
الامير هاري
تاريخ عائله مالك بحجم العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه ربما تقول همم بانه يجب على
العائله بان تكون وهذا ما قاله الامير
هاري في كتابه الذي طرح اليوم بان تكون
اكثر عصريه وان يعني تقرا عليها بعد
التغييرات والتبديلات في طريقه تعاملها مع
افرادها ومع الشعب اذا انت تستبعدين ان
تكون ان يكون هذا الكتاب نهايه الحكم
الملكي كيف نستطيع ردود الفعل داخل
المجتمع البري حول هذا الكتاب حول تصرفات
هذه الاخيره
هناك تباين واضح في التعليقات الصادره عن
البريطانيين الاقبال الشديد جدا على شراء
الكتاب لدرجه ان هناك محلات كبرى مثل
واترسونس وغيرها اضطرت لفتح ابوابها بعد
منتصف الليل ليله البارحه لكي ااه يعني
يتسنى لجميع لشراء الكتاب ولكن ليست هنا
بان الكتاب طرح اليوم وهو متوفر بنصف
السعر ولو انه الاكثر مبيعا والاكثر قراءه
لان طريقه كتابته همم من قبل همم
جميله جدا جدا
ولكن لا اعتقد بان ما يقوم به الامير هاري
سيغير الكثير همم من ترتيبات العائله
الملكيه ولم يكون هناك اي رد منهم واضح
طيب الان هاري يعبر عن ارادته بالمصالحه
ويتهم عائلته بانهم لا يريدون هذه
المصالحه او لا
بتصرفاتهم ولكن في المقابل ايضا يرى البعض
بانه هو من لا يعبر عن رغبته بالمصالحه
بهذه التصرفات والتسريبات والكتب
واللقاءات التي يخرج بها
من شاهد المقابلات التي اجراها ان كان على
اي تي في او على سي بي اس او جود مورنينج
امريكا همم يعني يمكن ان يشعر بان هناك
تناقض كبير يعيشه الامير هاري فهو يريد
العائله ولكنه لا يريد المؤسسه يريد همم
بان يعني يرجع الى عائلته ولكن همم لديه
الكثير من الشروط فهو يريد العائله ولكن
لا يريد بان يكون داخل العائله فهو يتخبط
في مشاعره وهذا يعود الى يوم وفاته والدته
ومن راقب تلك التصريحات التي قام بها وقرا
الكتاب انه كان متوفرا منذ حوالي خمسه
ايام في الاسواق الاسبانيه همم يمكن ان
يشعر بان الامير هاري همم مطرب نفسيا وهذا
يعود الى همم يوم وفاه والدته الجنه التي
مر بها ايضا وفاه والدتهم شكرا لك من لندن
فيها جوسلين ايليا
والان الى اخبار الاقتصاد مع زميله نادين
اليك
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا لنقم بجوله على تداولات
اسواق المنطقه اليوم فاذن ااا نبدا مع سعر
الدولار مقابل الجنيه المصري لانه كل يوم
عم نشوف المزيد من الضعف على الجنيه
المصري هذا الانخفاض التدريجي على سعر
العمله ولو انها رغم الارتفاعات الكبيره
على الدولار على الجنيب الايام الماضيه
لانه لا يزال بعيد عن السوق غير الرسميه
بمصر فاذا 27 65 بالوقت الحاضر عامل 27 66
الدولار على الجنابه على سعر هذه السوق
المصريه تعود لتراجع عليهم مؤشر يخسر واحد
فاصل اثنين بالمئه ننتقل الى اسواق
الخليجيه ونلق النظره عليها اليوم سوق
الاسهم السعوديه من بعد مكاسب فقط لواحد
بالمئه يوم امس اليوم على ثبات تجاه افقي
على السوق بدون اي تغيير سوق دبي وابو ظبي
سوقان على بعض تراجع نقطه مئويه السوق
الكويتيه المؤشر الاول اليوم كنا راينا
منذ مطلع التداولات الاسهم القياديه كلها
على ارتفاع بالسوق الكويتيه قطر على تراجع
بسته اشهر نقطه المئويه بالوقت الحاضر
نبدا منها سوق وبعض الاخبار التي نتبعها
الخريه في اعلنت ترسيه عقد من قبل شركه
المياه الوطنيه لتشغيل وصيانه شبكات
المياه والمحطات والابار بمنطقتين قيمه
العقد 33.5 مليون ريال تقول الشركه انه
الاثر هو بدا من الربع الثاني من 2023
اليوم ما بدات اكسترا بموسم النتائج
واعطتنا نتائج اعمالها المتحده
للالكترونيات سجل تراجع ثلاثه فاصل ثمانيه
بالمئه بارباح بربع الاخير من العام
الماضي الى 121 مليون 300,000 ريال اسهم
مع ذلك على ارتفاع بثلاثه بالمئه لانه على
صعيد الارباح الثانويه كان جيده اقوى باور
عم تصدر سقوط بريال مقومه بالريال بمليار
و800 مليون ريال مدتها سبع سنوات ولكن
يمكن استردها بعد خمس سنوات الوطنيه
للتعليم ايضا اعطتنا نتائج عماله سجلت
قفزه بثلاثه واربعين بالمئه باربع ربع
المنتهي بدي ديسمبر الى 26 مليون ريال في
ظل افتتاح مجمع تعليمي جديد وبالتالي
ارتفاع اعداد الطلاب ب 40% سريعا الى
شركات القياديه اليوم كيف تتداول في
فاذن سابق على ارتفاع معادن على تراجع
لوبرا فعل بعض التراجع تحت ال 97 البنوك
على نزول اليوم تلحظون ان كل القطاع
المصري فيه على نزول
ومن ضمنها البنك الراجحي بقطع الاتصالات
تباين زينه اللي كانت كسبت 3:15% يوم امس
على اخبار انها تبيع ان انتهت من البيعه
الابراج الى عائله الذهابيه اليوم تعود
للتراجع وهذه الاسهم الطاقه ارمكم على بعض
الارتفاع ب 10 انقتل المئويه سنكتفي بهذا
القدر الان اعود القاكم في برنامج الاسواق
العربيه بعد قليل العوده اليك فاطمه الان
شكرا نادين شكرا سكان في العاصمه صنعاء
ومدن يمنيه اخرى تحت سيطره الميليشيات
الحوثيه شكرا
بمختلف في انواعها وانتشار الفوضى
والعصابات الاجراميه المسلحه في مناطقهم
حسب ما ذكرت صحيفه الشرق الاوسط واقرات
الميليشيات الحوثيه بتسجيل اربع محافظات
خلال 30 يوما واكثر من 18,000 جريمه
جنائيه مختلفه
نجحت الطالبتان هنادي وجيهان من فتيات
مديريه حريب جنوب مارب في كسر الصوره
النمطيه عن الفتاه المغربيه
واستطاعتها دخول مجال الفن التشكيلي من
اوسع ابوابه وذلك برسم لوحات تشكيليه
مبهره باستخدام الخيط والابره في اسلوب
جديد من الرسمي في اليمن
المتميزات في مجتمع المغربي
ان يكون مغلقا بدون فرشاه او معجون
الالوان التي تستخدم في هذا الرسم بل
بالابره والخيط تمكنت من صناعه لوحات فنيه
غير تقليديه
همم اختلفنا من جهه اللون وبعد التفكير
والتفاك اتفاق اتمنى اللون الاسود والابيض
لتعاكس الالوان
رسمناها في تقريبا في تسع ساعات هذه
المقاله عرضناها شفناها اقبال كبير من
الجمهور اعجب بها طلبوا منها رسمات مختلفه
من مديريه حريب جنوبيه مارب حضر الكثير من
المبدعين في مجالات شتى وحضرت هنادي
وجيهان بفن تشكيلي جديد ولان معرض معرفه
الثاني للكتاب كان نافذه ثقافيه وابداعيه
على العالم فقد كان ايضا بوابتهما للشهره
من خلال اللوحات والرسومات التي لاقت
رواجن كبيره حيث بدات بشخصيه المعرض واديب
اليمن الراحل عبد العزيز
المقالحسين احنا كمان فخر وكان في اقبال
كثير من الناس علينا والحمد لله طبقنا اول
تجربه شخصيه مشهوره والحمد لله ضبطت معنا
وبعدين جربنا الثاني تجربه
محل الكتروني المتجر الالكتروني يعني
مفتوح وان شاء الله نحصل اقبال من الاشخاص
ماربو ارض الحضاره والتاريخ بموروثها
ومخزنها الانسانيه والاثري الشامل هي
المشروع القادم للفتياتها المبدعات في
متجر الكتروني كان فكره وصار بعد هذا
الاقبال جاهزا لطلب اللوحات الفنيه محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب
من اليمن الى الاردن وبعد توقف منصه تيك
توك هناك عن العمل لمده ثلاثه اسابيع اكد
الناطق الرسمي باسم الحكومه الاردنيه فيصل
الشبول ان هناك حوار انتقاليا قانونيا مع
شركه تيك توك بعد قرار الحكومه السابق
بحجبه لبثه محتوى موسيئا من قبل البعض على
خلفيه احتجاجات رافقه ارتفاع اسعار
المحروقات
توقفت منصه تيك توك في الاردن وما زال
الخلاف قائما بدايه لم يكن السيد غيث
متقبلا لتلك المساحه الكبيره التي حاضت
بها المنصه من حياه ابنائه واليوم يرفض
ابنائه غيابها اما هو فكان من اكثر
المرحبين بهذا الغياب انا بطالب بمواصله
ايقاف هذا التطبيق لانه زي ما حكيت مكان
لنشر التفاهه مكان للتحريض مكان للقتال
الخطاب الكراهيه ومكان لنشر الاكاذيب فيه
اشياء سلبيه في اشياء ايجابيه
وبظهر لكل شخص حسب اهتماماته لانه هو بضيع
من وقت البني ادم مش انه بساعدك بالعكس
اساءه استخدام المنصه على خلفيه احتجاجات
مواطنين حول ارتفاع اسعار المحروقات في
الاردن كانت السبب في توقفها منذ ثلاثه
اسابيع وما بين رافض ومؤيد ان قسمت اراء
الشارع بس نفسي افهم ايش دخل التيك توك
بالي عم بتصير ليشطبوا يعني تكتب كان شيء
كثير بسلي
على الهاتف لكنه لا يعمل الا ان البعض ذهب
لمواقع في بي ان لفك الحظر ومتابعه منصته
التي اثر غيابها على وجوه اعتمدتها لشهره
ومصدر للرز
يزعل يشيل الخط الارضي او بس يزعل مني
يعني تقدر مثلا اذا في فيديو في فيديو
خارج النص يقدر تكتب
[موسيقى]
من زمان
هدف الاردن اما عن فرنسا فيتعرض النظام
الصحي لشلل في بعض اجزائه بعد ان تفاقمت
ازمه نقص الاطباء والادويه نتابع
بعد ان كان النظام الصحي الفرنسي يتصدر
القائمه كافضل النظام صحيا في العالم لعام
بعد اليوم يواجه عقبه كبيره تضعه على
المحك وتضع الدوله ايضا امام مسؤولياتها
للخروج من هذه الازمه باسرع وقت ممكن خلال
هذا العام كما وعد وزير الصحه الفرنسي
النظام الصحي في فرنسا ليس بافضل حال هذه
الايام ففي ظل انتشار الامراض والاوبئه
المعديه يتعرض هذا القطاع لهذه قويه تجعله
بحاجه ماسه للاصلاح خاصه مع استمرار ازمه
نقص الاطباء وعدم توفر بعض الادويه هذا ما
اكده لنا هذا الطبيب العام
في الحصول على رعايه صحيه منتظمه وهناك
ضغط كبير على الاطباء
فهم مرهقون ومتعبون ويحاولون ترك القطاع
العام لصالح الخاص وهذا ما يؤدي الى تدهور
الوضع لذا يجب اجراءه اصلاحات عاجله
القطاع الخاص احتجاجاتهم واضراباتهم مؤخرا
اشتكى مواطنون من صعوبه الوصول الى
المختصين للعلاج
في المستشفى نجد 20 شخصا امامنا ونبقى
لساعه طويله ولا يوجد مكان حتى لكبار السن
الجلوس
عندما يكون لديك طفل مصاب بالحمى هناك
فعلا نقص في الاطباء وهذه مشكله كبيره
ليس كذلك فعليهم اي ينتظر ايا من عده او
اسابيع للوصول الى للوصول الى الاطباء
التي بدات بتنفيذ قطه اصلاح شامله للقطاع
الصحي تتمثل في توظيف المزيد من عاملي
الصحه ورفع الاجور مع السماح للصيدليات
بتوالي بعض المهمات الطبيه التي تساهم في
تخفيف الضغط على المستشفيات زين عادي
العربيه باريس
في بريطانيا اعلنت شركه
اول صاروخ الى الفضاء الخارجي انطلاقا من
الاراضي البريطانيه وفي تغريده على تويتر
ارجلت الشركه السبب في فشل المهمه الى
وجود خلل تقنيه منع وصول الصاروخ الى
المدارس
الى العناوين
تقارير امريكيه تتحدث عن سفينه روسيه رست
في جنوب افريقيا وتحمل شحنه اسلحه مخبئه
للكرملين
حاله الطوارئ اذا فشل مجلس النواب والدوله
في التوافق بشان الانتخابات
سريه كانت بحوزته
في الختام الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]